thank you very much for coming and today
we are going to talk about
about what
and its share slides
so the
um the strategy I'm going to follow is
to explain a bit of theory and just the
talking about why we need architecture
and things beforehand and then we are
going to have some kind of real world
application you can follow alongside
with me and type a code but it's not a
requirement I'm going to make it a
smoother for you you can just watch and
then ask the questions in the middle as
well
yeah that's it case
we are so this is the first time of mine
to be in a pycon conference I'm quite
excited and again thank you for coming
uh hexagonal python services and how to
build them the the today's agenda is
about me and our python User Group
and then it's going to a bit of
historical reasoning how it started
about me and a better way to teach
complex topics so we are constantly
searching to teach people with complex
topics and there's a kind of still
um have a better way better room for
that kind of things and the few words
about maintainable software fewer words
about about architectures and then we
get started with the
with the coding
point I use a community it's founded in
2015 we have we are active in a telegram
and a Discord
the predominant communication languages
azerbaijani and we do live streams how
ping each other elsewhere in the
questions and doing a local and online
meetups obviously
uh this is my cardio waves it's
okay it cannot be interesting enough but
why are calling this for the Raves
because there are a lot of bathing in
our life and my career just mirrored my
life decisions these kind of waves and
chords I started the Linux system admins
and a bunch of things dropping uh Master
degrees and going through the software
engineering and four months ago I have
relocated to the Berlin as a senior
software engineer and I work for the not
security as a we are seniors of
Engineering in Street intelligence team
this is my race
and it all started from this wonderful
book
standard C in 2009 and yeah less than
please then is Richie and thanks Brian
Kent again to give me a chance to change
my life actually and first thing I built
was a simplest of a calculator and I
cannot share this kind of exciting that
all men as a chord it's compiled
successful it's with the ways I did gets
an input it adds two numbers and wow
that was magic for me the first time and
they kept anymore that that I've I have
graduated in a finance this was a total
news thing for me so I didn't see any
kind of court before
and then after a decade I found this
book it's architecture patterns with
python and thanks again Harry and Bob
for this wonderful uh book and it the
samples the sample code and applications
they built in the
in the book it says somehow complicated
for new buys and I just remember that
the how I started the first time and it
was a building in the calculator and the
question is that why not to build the
same thing but using Enterprise
architecture patterns so just start with
a simple then go to the complex topics
and today we are going to build this
kind of application but we are going to
over engineer things
uh okay the question can't be right to
botso with an architecture patterns and
other stuff
so the main topic is what is a software
maintenance so you can develop the
application or the product for two years
and if obviously somebody is going to
use your product you are going to still
wait for in a maintenance state for 15
20 years until you are going I don't
know bankruptcy or somebody acquire you
and pay more money
uh This Is It the most crucial things I
don't remember about the software and
there's a distribution of Maintenance
effort distribution for the software and
as you see the 67 percent of the effort
is going to maintain the software
and the people with a brilliant mind
came to uh to the solutions or what kind
of Maintenance uh types we have and the
basically this is a endless loop so we
monitor we enhance the software we
support the software and then we bugger
fixes uh
fix a box and then it's going the
containers with the with the loop so
what is uh what does it mean for
enhancement the people in the business
can add a few features so you can add a
support efforts for
for your customers or you have a bunch
of bugs and you need to fix it
uh the next question is a what is a
maintainable software and how to use
this for process the maintainable
software is a combination of festival
extensible and understandable software
but you can add other LEDs like
observable software and other stuff also
so what is a testable if the software is
it easy to test it is a testable is it a
change modify extent at method
extensible and low cognitive load when
you onboard somebody new in your team in
your project if it's a higher load of
the cognitive uh dissonance that means
that you have a
a higher cognitive complexity and it's
not understandable at all and if you
combine all three you got the
maintainable software
and of course this is not most easy in
in general and the people came around
with the ideas how to simplify things
and they invented this only on clean and
the hexagonal architectures the
hexagonal architecture is a different
name as ports and adapters you can
search for it as well and the question
is what is common for all these
architectures
um yeah I'm asking you
correct the first commonality is
direction of coupling or direction of
dependencies it goes from outside to
inwards versus from inverse to outside
and the the second commonality
what you see here
what's a comma
they're all architectures centered the
domain model
so this is a heart of the complexity of
the software this is a where the
business logic or the problem you are
trying to fix sits there and that's why
they sent Earth admits that this is a
most crucial part of your application
but as you say there's other
commonalities the user interface tests
Frameworks UI database external systems
I don't know web Frameworks are sit
outside of the architecture that means
there are details we can see the
database
and the Frameworks As a detail and it
will be addressed when we really need it
so this is a crucial part about the
architectures just focus on the domain
model or just focus on the business
domain what you are your software is
going to fix what kind of solution you
are going to to invent
uh yeah the next is we have this app
requirement the wonderful app
requirements so our calculator should do
it should have plus the API 8 support to
add subtract multiply and divide numbers
it should store the result of actions in
the database the calculator operates
only with two numbers because it was
easy to write and add subtract multiply
and divide our supported only supported
actions so you have this kind of draft
of the requirements and this the the
first thing that the most of us is going
to have
how do you want to start to build this
application and usually when you follow
all the tutorials they are directly
starting from the database modeling or
they are directly starting from the
installing a framework it building is an
API and going through all this help as
the first hand
but this is a way it's starting to go
wrong
let's just revert the ideas how we
should act
what we do we usually forget about we
forget about the business domain logic
or this centralized section of the
architecture the core of the software
and how it should look like instead you
should like this one so we first start
from the domain models then goes upwards
to the layers no framework yet no
database yet and this is a crucial part
of of architecturing the things
why I have two app requirements okay
this is
sorry
we have an application it's called this
hexagonal architecture we can right now
install it and use it and also there's a
guide for the running test for running
uh running at actual fast API and
flashings but instead I would like to
um to go directly to the with the code
and to start the code settings
to get started what we need we need to
create a vulture
and I'm going to just copy from my from
my slides
I have actually the terminal the size is
small right
and it increase
okay is it okay
yeah good
and yeah just create some kind of
hexagonal calculator
and goes to the the vulture
then what we need we need to
get in it as an empty repo
the second is we need to register as a
remote origin
here the way that we can do it
and we can verify remote not remove we
and we have added this remote repository
as well the second the the next step is
uh fetchings are in mood
fetch
through the mood
it's going to fetch all the commit
history as well and for understanding
the things that if you can grab all
commit hashes from remote origin and the
reverse order that means we're the first
commit is a it shows that with the
initial complete
and here is the output from the git log
and this is an initial combat this
initial commit of full just structures
and other stuff and we are going to use
a different thing here I'm going to
cherry pick
through the Commit hashes This is a new
way that I'm trying to
um like to show you
and then we can just fire up our python
I use pycharm you can use different sync
as well
but boy charm has this
neat git extension that's a pretty
useful
no I don't want and I need to remove
this
I have shaded in the the Discord room
Channel yes I have shared the slides and
reportedly as well
font
font bigger okay
sure sure
I need to find how it was yeah it's Ctrl
alt S I believe and
editor font
Zoom where
okay there's a control s
appearance
okay
oh yeah
oh nice thank you very much
is it okay
if you want but okay you want you want
more
sure sure
that's better
much better thank you very much for
for helping me
and in order to get works just we need
the Tommy Tommy first commit so I'm
going to create some kind of python
and python txd
and if we did check out
be Main
and then get status we have this Pike
County standard idea I'm going to
jit add pycon txt
and then get commit
this is a
initial
commit
and then we open we can open this git
and if we go
to the main of the remote Branch we can
see all this
uh commit history
and what we can have here the initial
commit and we can cherry pick this
change if you hit inside and this is a
nice Cherry icon you can cherry pick and
that's it so we have this first initial
commit from our remote Branch this is
just license get ignore and read me
nothing fancy the second thing that we
can cherry pick is the Folger structure
and let's go through the folders folder
structure our hexagonal architecture a
hexagonal calculator have source and
tests inside the source we have domain
inside the domain model ports and
adapters and that's why it's called the
hexagonal architecture so the other name
of this architecture is the ports and
inductors
and this is a way that I'm going to
follow the tutorial try to pick the
commits and explain is it okay for
everybody I I guess it's a more
yeah
ah
amazing
lighter is it lighter no yeah
it's the same for me so I'm I don't know
it's maybe material Sandy
how about now
um
material sky blue it's the first time
I'm checking those kind of thing
it's okay now
good
nice feedback from the people so we have
constructed our phone just structure the
next is as we have talked about the
domain modeling the centralizing other
domains and and if we go back to the app
requirement
the app requirement states that uh
calculators operates only with two
numbers and that means it's a court
problem we have eliminated the first API
side we have eliminated as a database
side and we directly going to address
the domain modeling and this is a like
creating a class for operands and let me
show you how just simple enough so add
operands it's just adding the model.pi
file and if you click it
now we have this model pi and the model
pi
is just a data class in a terminology
where this is a value object
but just don't stack with the
terminology it's a class and the
operands it has left and right and it
has returning in the the hash because to
make it an unhatchable and it has an
equality check we can see the operands
to be equal only and only if the left
and right values are equal together
the next
the next is to add
um to add
let's see what I'm going to add
um yeah it's a it's a this strategy
called to create and get domain
factories and it's just simply turning
back the operands domain model
uh why it's powerful you can add
validation domain validation and extra
things inside the operands factory
instead of making this validation inside
the class domain model should stay pure
an opulence Factory can handle all these
validation stuff
and as we have the all kind of why it's
um
disabled
uh yeah the next thing of course we have
added the first domain model we have
added the factory that means we net we
can add the unit tests
nowhere without tests the testing domain
models and testing domain models the
test if operance is created test if
opulence is created with Factory and you
can check with the names that it's
intuitive test if operands is created
with wrong types
and uh and this is a there's a bunch of
text Suites that we have here
how to install and run the test if you
go to the project normal we are going to
build system as a fleet we are going to
use a fleet for our build system and
then you have a calculator after you
osers I don't know read me Dynamic
requires a python and dependencies this
is a production dependencies and we are
going to use dependence injector
containers here and that's why I just
installed it beforehand optional
dependencies the black eye sword
autoflake and other stuff that you need
to have to have in your project for
common style linting checks type checks
and security check and other stuff and
for the test we are going to use Point
test and practice cooperation and for
the make file
and the python has also this neat
thing so we have make linked make this
coverage for all of things and also we
have this install div you can hit it
it fails for ah we have not a virtual
environment then we need to create it
um
again running this install div
and now it says a no model named flit
because we need to install the fleet for
this
and I'm going to Source when bin
activate
and pip
flip install install
Ed three seven one
and then again once again I'm trying to
install the div
it picks up all the dependencies it
install everything for me
um it's trying to install and we have
finished and now we can what happened
here
okay anyway and now we can go to the
terminal and run make test
and all our tests have been passed
this is aware so I stick with the make
files because it is it's easy to develop
with make files but you can always run
the commands directly so no dots there
we have added first bunch of
test we have added our domain model the
next thing
the next thing if you spot the domain
model it it's going to it has no
validation on it
this is a quite
um
like flow for us and we need to address
this I'm going to use marshmallow for
the domain
validation and so nowadays that
everybody can to use it like pedantic
things but it's the marshmallow also for
serialization deserialization but it's
also powerful for creating a details the
dto is a domain is a data transfer
object and we add an abstraction over
the domain model
to validate we do not insert the
validation inside the domain model
I just added
not this one
and here we create a schemas
and we ins we import the exclude schema
fields from the marshmallow and it's
just a schema with left and right you
specify they are required to
and also it has handy class meta which
is unknown exclude if somebody tries to
inject a noun field to our schema it's
going to just exclude ignored
this is a case that we can use and of
course we have a project tomorrow which
we have Aptoide updated the dependencies
and that means we can run install Dev to
grab this dependency
and if we go back to schema this is not
a redage thing here
how about model
we don't even use it but I believe I
have added some tests here
yes
we have we have added the unit test for
creating a detail and we have this test
if operands create opens create it
you're created
and we created The meshmallow Works in
this way you first declare a schema you
then load the dictionary to the schema
and it's going through the validation
and if it's validated it returns back
the specified type of the dictionary
and this is a quite neat for API
development as well it's just operates
on a dictionary it's quite intuitive
and test if operands create detail can
be created with wrong types now we are
going to try to inject a wrong type
which is a left is a list and it fails
with a marshmallow exceptions validation
error we have decoupled the validation
from the domain models because it it
it's not responsibility of the domain
models itself
uh the gains at the right side is if you
try to insert the string it's going to
fail with the validation
validation error and we can run this
test
as again Mac test we have added five
tests which all the past green green we
like green
so next
the next is adding more tests for
adding more tests for where why is that
there
okay let's
so add open Creator marshmallow schema
we have added add more tests for
operands create dto we have adding the
bunch of
um a bunch of tests as well for the
opponents criteria which is quite so
this one is new test if open create
detail can be created with extra Fields
as you see we are trying to inject an
extra field to our schema but it's going
to exclude it
because of this meta exclude
quite wise
uh how about the models isn't changed no
I believe
yes now we are going to change our
Factory domain Factory and let's cherry
pick it with the domain Factory we have
the schema operands create detail inside
we create a model
of the operand and then validate
inside the factory if it's if it's valid
widely created the type of at least and
we'll return back the model so this is a
so just wrapping up we have created the
domain model operands we have added a
validation with marshmallow schema we
have decoupled the validation logic
outside of the domain model then we use
operands Factory to create opponents
model with a validation
this is a
yeah
this is the first things that we have
addressed the question so far yeah
uh
yeah sure
the question was that fast API has
built-in product validation
and it's validated at the API
layer right but here we are validating
the domain model so the question is
could we exploit a bit more right the
thing is what I'm doing I'm validating
each layer on its own layer so you
should not delegate the validation to
the upper sides in term of that the
service layers validation should go
alongside with the service layer the
domain model validation should go
alongside the domain models the use case
validation should go with the use case
and API validation should go with the
API layer
and this is quite powerful when your
proper architecture sinks when
Frameworks just forces you to use some
kind of tool you just can ignore them
and as you see at the end that we are
using marshmallow and we don't use
pythanding and what our first API API
will work so it's kind of it's a
validation logic it just goes alongside
the each layer
does make sense or you need okay good
yeah sure
please thank you
um one question is do we need to know
domain driven development if we want to
develop in hexagonal manner
not at all you can
build an application without DDT and as
you see we are using just small portions
of DDD so with the DDD there's a kind of
Aggregates aggregate route and other
stuff that can be developed but here the
mostly I don't need such complexities
but you can always use it the hexagonal
architecture Union and the clean they
are pretty agnostic on what kind of
internal architecture you are using uh
so the question is no no need for DDD
thank you next question why create a
model in parenthesis data class
and a schema in parenthesis marshmallow
when you can create both in one go with
marshmallow data class
good question
so this is elsewhere
the same seat goes with the pedantic
schemas right you can create a model
with a pedantic schema you can create a
marshmallow schema
but the thing is that your domain model
should not depend on anything as you see
our like operands it's pure class it
just use built-in python C python data
class there's no third-party dependence
on it if you put an OU third part of
dependencies in your domain models you
are in trouble on testing and also it's
not a flexible
enough what we the requirement for the
domain models it should stay the pure
as it can be
and then you can extract add that extra
layer with a much smaller up identic you
can replace the schema here with the
pedantic but the domain model doesn't
care about what kind of Technology you
use it's just a class
it's just the information
thank you one more question why do you
keep the validation separate from the
model
good
[Music]
um
the obvious answer is that what I want
to have a dependency flow
with the domain models
if I have created the object and in the
Constructor of object I am going to
validate the things this is a reason to
change my domain model if my validation
changes in the future this is a
violation of single responsibility
principle from the solid
the class should have only one reason to
change and only one reason to change the
domain model change dictated by the
business change not the validation
change or validation logic change and
that's why we have shifted our
validation outside of the domain model
and stays the pure validated that in in
some in the future the business there's
a kind of validation check now we want
for example password lengths to be 10. I
don't want to touch the domain model
because it's a crucial part it's a
center a heart of the complexity of our
application for the simple reason that
the password links has been changed but
instead validator should be responsible
for the validation logic this is a one
more thing
this is a Django related question I'm
not sure if you are so much into Django
would you use a Django model to define
the domain model or would you use Django
only on the outside layer
with Django it's
pretty complicated because Django Orem
is just the heart of the Django it just
started to start from the Django model
and that's why it's quite complicated to
apply some kind of architectures but in
in this book architectural patterns with
python orb and Harry defined a way of
abstracting things in a Django so you
can read the book there's a kind of
appendix
about this topic and for the Django it's
not
opinioned the framework in terms it
dictates the rules and its envity so the
Django itself is an embassy or nvt
framework
but instead like Sonic flask a fast API
and other stuff is just open it equates
flexible on this you can react extra
things with a different Frameworks
last tiny thing maybe you will answer
that later I'm not sure what are ports
on the adapters anyway
um yeah so maybe we defer that to later
and we go on with the presentation oh
one more question here from the audience
thank you sorry my question is when I
have a domain model I really want to
make sure that it is impossible to
create a
instances of the model with inconsistent
state
so I'm wondering like if you have
certain rules
in your domain model
[Music]
like of of potential states that would
be inconsistent or incorrect how would
you prevent them from being created
um
the question is that to prevent the
creation of the domain model
this is some something like this maybe
maybe this I think maybe this would be a
solution yeah is there a way to do this
or would you have then a different
validation in your domain model how
would you solve it
you can have double check in your domain
model if you will but I do not do the
validation inside the domain models at
least inside the value objects but what
you can do uh to so you define that
contract in your team in your project
that if you want to create a domain
model you should operate with the
factories that's the only way to create
it and this is the only way okay
creating and if you see some some like
merge request or put requests that the
people trying to access it in domain
model directly just to not merge it okay
and this is kind of cultural change
inside the team so they should accept
that there is no way to directly access
domain models there's some kind of quiz
did it this if you have Aggregates and
you have aggregate route it's a hard to
hit but with this kind of architecture
you should just
um I don't know give a workshop for your
team that hey please do this and like
this way create a proper documentation
on it I don't know create an RFC design
record all the stuff that we can go
thank you
thank you then let's go on yeah yeah
sure thanks
and now we are done with what we are
done with the calculator operates only
with two numbers we have created a value
object or domain first domain model
the second thing is add subtract
multiply and divide actions what we can
do with that I'm going to create a
service
for this you are going to have a you can
call this domain service or you can call
it just a Services layer
and if we actually pick Implement
operands add action
inside the port we have created the
services
and inside the services there's a
operands.pi an operands is an interface
in Python we have no like golang like
interfaces but obviously we can't force
it with abstract basic base classes and
operand service interface has this left
and right
um at functionalities just adding
summing up
the summing up the numbers obviously
but if you see that we have public
method add and inside the public method
we are returning the protected method
and the protected method or private
message underscore add is an abstract
method what kind of question can arise
here we Define operand service interface
and what is an interface interface is a
contract
we agree that somebody who is going to
implement our interface is going to
implement this underscore ad
why we need it
there's a kind of open course principle
in from the solid or from the solid it
dictates
that the interfaces should open for the
extension
but should be close for the modification
for the changing
and we have already shaped our hands so
we have agreed that we have a public ad
but in the future if you want to change
the behavior as is public at what what
to do just re-implemented underscore at
do not touch the Public Public method
public contract because we have already
agreed but if you want to change it
by a minute you want to extend it
then you are going to change this
underscore add and implement it in a
different way so imagine that you have a
fancy thing that your calculator not
adding but subtracting with the ad you
fool the people you can change down the
ad without touching the public ad
this is a
this is a naive way of achieving this
open close
I would call it in instead of like just
having abstract class where we add
function public ad function is abstract
but has to be implemented by some
yeah is a good question but the thing is
that the public method
you give a public method to the contract
implementer the interface will Implement
and you agree that okay this is not
going to change in the future right and
in the like at some point if you need
some kind of change you are going back
to change your interface
it prevents the change of the interval
you do not touch this public ad
inside the inside the interface itself
it's a one way of achieving it but it's
a tool that you can also use a force
that to re-implement the publics
but I came to reinforce to re-implement
the privates because the public we have
already agreed that we we don't want to
re-implement the thing
there's a one this design decision
obviously you can change it but this is
what
of this I think that it's that proper
way but it's always there's a better
ways
this is a port size of in the yeah the
question okay
yeah sorry I'm new to python so I did a
bit of hexagonal architecture with go
and you can use interface
but you don't have this concept of
abstract classes and I'm not super fan
of inheritance and I heard of protocols
but I wonder why not use protocols here
and where to use abstract class
uh yeah nice question with the protocols
it's hard to ensure the Integrity so
it's it's just duct typing for the
patterns there is no kind of runtime
check if it's truly implemented it's all
kind of methods inside the interface but
with abstract based classes I can force
it I can rise at runtime error it's not
not implemented at all if somebody
missed this
so that's why I'm forcing the people
that hey if you want to conform with my
interface with my contract you have no
other choice at implementing this but
with protocols you can omit it it's just
close your eyes because there's no
runtime check
yes in places so it's kind of I'm
defining that explicitly
that that you should implement this you
must Implement what you must implement
this is a correctable
cannot continue
yeah great this is a port side as you
see in a port side we have services and
interfaces
in contrast in a vector side we have
services
but we have a concrete implementation of
this interface and in operant service we
inherit from the interface and create
this and implement this underscore ad
functionality it's just creating a data
dictionary with left and right then it
validates with a marshmallow because we
want to use this operands create detail
while creating our operands and then we
create the operands domain model and
afterwards we add these two numbers so
did you see the layers the service hits
a schema annotation
the schema validation
calls after schema validation we call
this domain Factory domain Factory
creates a domain model and returns back
this is an idea so we have layered
and that means that we can have a test
right now
let's have a test for our service add
functionality
the charter pick
and it go to the test we have the
services
for the test Services we are going to
check the test operand service add
result
we have this fixture
called get operand service if you go to
the fixture it just creates an operand
service instance and returns it you can
use this later on with your tests and we
are asserting that okay actually the
addition was correct then the next the
test operand service add with the wrong
data types we're trying to inject the
wrong data tiles to our service layer
but it will catch by the marshmallow
that hits the validation error we have
covered our safety net
with that
more unit tests yeah sure we love this
the test operand service at result we
are just adding a bunch of tests here
also and making sure that the left side
and the right side if you insert the
wrong type it's going to fail with the
validation a roof at the end
uh then it's kind of subtraction it's a
pretty simple it's the same thing we can
go to operands and see that we have at
the end this is a total same thing and
at the end we are going to subtract the
same thing for the multiply I'm just
going to quickly through that the
multiply the multiply and the Divide as
a divide
and this is a kind of
um encapsulated the actions inside the
service
but if you see that we have duplicated a
chord portions and that's why I'm going
to introduce a contacts manager which is
quite neat so
from contact slip import context manager
and here we are yielding the actual
operands domain model
and inside the service we can use with
operands Factor validation and it is
indeed a factory validation
and then get the operands and return the
the actual result
so we have
implemented the context manager in order
to eliminate this duplication
and also we have extracted the
validation logic out the service as you
see
now is the responsibility of the context
manager not the service because as a
context manager validate the schema
and let's say so what we have
okay obviously
this is the most
well-known prominent
exception zero Division and now we can
hit it here but I'm going to show you uh
another pattern called design by
contract or DBC where you can cover your
your code portions with the contracts so
what we mean if we go and show the
pixels defend let's just go defend
divide action from zero division using
contract
and for this purposes let me just go
to the project tunnel inside the Pi
Project tunnel we have a new dependency
called eye contract eye contract is a
library which is implements are designed
by contract pattern it's quite powerful
for your domain models it has predic
Wizards Wizard and then it was an
invariant check
if you have a question what is a class
invariant it's a state that should be
always true through the lifetime of your
application or through the lifetime of
the class you can Define the
your invariant with the icon track and
if you go back to the operance adapters
here we simply Define that I contract
require
right side to be not equal for specific
divide actions this is a difference in
what we usually see in the tutorials the
the most of the things that we are going
to try except then catch the zero
Division and then act according to write
and now you see that there's a contract
I require before hitting my divide the
right side should not be inequal it's a
different kind of thinking and there's
not need for for creating a validation
to do catch exception inside the The
Divide action
we have excluded again this
responsibility outside of of the service
and delegate it to the eye contract
uh what you can use for the eye contract
is it has you can stack this
um obviously it's a decorator you can
stack the all decorators and create a
different rules for your critical
section this is our critical section
because I don't want to see the zero on
the right side that's it
and if we check the test
let's go back to the tests let's check
if we now we have concluded with the
cherry picking let's go to the test and
inside the test services this is quite
interesting just uh maybe you can
you can see this so
we expect
the not zero division error we expect a
violation error this is a violation of
the contract because we have defined
that we don't want to see the zero on
the right side
and if you want to violate you hit by
the eye contract and that's a violation
error so you can checks the difference
this is a validation error because it
validates it hits already desire and
validates the violation is just you
violate the rule
is a different
um
like mental thinking State I would say
and this is a quite powerful tool you
can use for your applications just check
it designed by contract DBC I contract
Library
quite neat if we are I want to install
it
and then for sure runs a test just to be
sure that we don't make anything a 15
test past green we are done
we are pretty happy
yeah the next
okay the requirement has been met I'd
say that we have operands we have the
service and now the this section it
should store the result of actions in
the database but we are interested in
this first part
the question that we need to ask to like
stakeholders interested part what is the
action for you and what is the result
for you and that obvious answer for our
calculator action is some kind of add
multiply divide and
subtract and the result is a result of
these actions and when you write down
the words okay you should go back to the
domain modeling because you should model
your ideas
and if you
um yeah so here add calculation model
and Factory I'm going to check it pick
and again once again we are going to
model
and now we have this data class
called the calculation the calculation
something that has uid unique uid
something that has left right action
result and created add an update the add
fields
the calculation factor is responsible
for instantiating the uid I'm using ulit
it is from
python unit you can check why it's
better than the ordinary uid4
but it's a different topic and you can
yeah you can check it on your own let's
just install it quickly and it's
installed
uh go back to the model
and here if you
if you think about that what we can have
the differently we can have a
calculation class within it the
Constructor and we can create this uid
inside the Constructor and once again we
don't want to do in any initialization
for the domain models we delegate it to
outside the calculation Factory and it
is now responsible for creating uids
it's also responsible for extracting the
action type an action type is an enum
which just predefines the actions it's
quite simple add subtract If I multiply
which has its own values and the
calculation factor is responsible for
creating uids for extracting the option
action type for
instantiating the date time so it's
called date time so all these
responsibilities not burdened inside the
domain model but it goes for the factory
so next
we need to add the calculation create
the question
no
uh sorry
the question that with ulit we have
added a dependencies for our domain
model
but if you see our domain model you are
we are storing string
yes
ah you mean that Y is a calculation
factor to use you okay this is a good
good question the idea was that if your
calculation Factory Depends for the
third party Library you can extract out
from the domain model layer that's
correct I'm totally agree but the case
of the simplest just imagine that it's a
kind of extra layer and before you hit
your domain model it goes to the factory
so
yeah yeah this is a
um that's a good point thanks
and the yeah the next we need to create
a dto for our create model
let's go to the schema
add inside that
um
so now we are afraid to done with your
uh with your logic so you say that you
should extract out this your lead and I
don't know validation steps now we are
extracted this to the outside schema and
inside the uid we have this load default
which is a callable we store it we
create a unit
with our marshmallow schema then we
validate it as one of this is going to
so that the action should be one of the
keys from the enum
and also we are creating a date times
inside the schema and the class meta
just ignores the unknown exclude
and let's go back what is next change
the calculation Factor amazing so we
need to change the calculation Factory
the calculation factor in now just
accepts the uid we have eliminated your
concern and here we just add an extra
layer of the schema validation so the UI
UI the creation and also the action UI
declaration is delegated to the schema
now our calculation factor is simply
accepts any kind of information from the
outside
uh obviously I hit a circular
input issue here sorry for that and I'm
going to fix it the idea was that we
have now this kind of
requirement inside the schema as well
this is a double check the first
the so what we have the first things
that we have is the schema calculation
create detail is just validates against
the strings and inside the model we have
extra validation with the inner type
this is a double check of that because
the action part is a crucial is a
crucial part uh for us
so next
uh obviously I had a failing test and I
need to pick to fix this let's go to the
test then
with our tech services
um
what kind of
I need I need I need I want it was um
okay so I need to test it
yes the old tests have been passed I
need to find this calculation model
because I'm I'm in the wrong place I
need to check the test domain models
this is a this is a place there where we
are creating a calculation so test if
calculation model created the wizard
Factory calculation created your now
calculation Factory accepts just the
keyword arguments and if you go to the
calculation Factor we have just changed
it
we have added an extra check for for the
action
as well so there's a double check why
I'm going to explain it
uh so if you are going to test if
calculation model created with Factory
with wrong action
if it's going to
if we are going to use it with the wrong
fake action we hit the marshmallow it
says validation error but we can always
bypassing
we can create a proper dictionary then
we can check the action and then we can
we want to inject this to our
calculation Factory and because the enum
checks this direction it fails at the
enum level so as a double check ensure
that our domain model not
it's treated properly I would say
and we have all tests passed
good
yeah sure
okay
um
I'm going in some randomized order
what if we want to add additional action
type or types
will we have to change the validation as
well
yes sure if you need to add an extra
validation for a new uh new action type
that was obviously yeah
you can you can centralize it you can
create some kind of common settings
and you can grab all kind of actions
from the common place or you can store
it some kind of a database with the
support of actions and you can insert
the new action to the database and fetch
there there's a kind of different styles
you can follow next one
how do you not confuse the database
implementations storing details and the
domain model meaning that is easy to
pollute the model with too many details
again
how do you not confuse the database
implementation storing details and the
domain model
all right so the question I guess is
about decoupling the orium side or the
database layer with a domain model we
will see it because we have this commit
regarding to this reports to the
patterns and unit of work pattern and
then abstracting the orium side from the
domain model
the obvious solution is that when you
start your application you map your
domain model with your Orem model but
it's only with the start you don't need
it anymore so it's just started math and
use
it will it will be clear in a moment
yeah okay thanks
um
why do we specify the eye contract in
the implementation and not the interface
uh in the interface
we cannot force what kind of
implementation that people should choose
we just give a contract that a you want
to create this add or divide action
right and the implementer is responsible
for further actions the validations the
interface is just the public facing so
we I have this one you need to implement
I have this one with two arguments you
need to implement it you cannot force or
you should not force the people
stick with eye contract
it's it's a detail it's a like one
possible solution maybe the people want
to use a different Solution that's why
that's why it should delegate to the
implementer
thank you
why do you define double underscore hash
double underscore
on a mutable data class
what's immutable on a mutable data
um yeah obviously the value objects uh
you can use this is frozen true to make
it immutable
but yeah I have omitted this process it
it should not be checked it should not
be changed in the runtime but we're
creating a hash
first of all that
why I've created because I want to to
make this object hashable
and want at some point to store it as a
for example a key in a dictionary my
domain model right and if you implement
fashion equal it's possible this that
was the reason for me at least but if
you know some kind of other
I don't know anti-pattern you can show
it
obviously so we can learn thank you
choose the next one what is the effect
of the meta class you added in the
schema validation
uh yeah that's a good question let's
just clarify it
no so here all right in a schema
validation we declare that if the field
is unknown we need to exclude it the
reason is that somebody can try to
inject some kind of fake field to the
schema
and our system instead of checking all
the fields checking the field count I
don't know all the extra check I'm going
to exclude it I'm going not to take it
take it into account this is a the
unknown exclude so it's it's a feature
of the the marshmallow I just use it
yeah
thank you one more question life here
the audience no let's move on great
uh yes and now we are done with this
requirements we it should store the
result of the actions we have defined
what is the result what is the action
it's a calculation domain model and this
is a China part in the database we love
it and we are going to implement it
right now but we are going to abstract
away the database implementation using
repository pattern that just goes
through Implement calculation repository
pattern the children pick
inside the port now we have these
repositories
this is a kind of interface you know
and inside the adapters we have this
calculation the calculation SQL Alchemy
Repository
from the name it's clear that we are
going to use SQL Alchemy orium for our
purposes it's related to the calculation
and it is a repository it implements
calculation repository interface what it
has
it has this underscore add which is
adding
self-session is is a connection to the
database from the SQL Alchemy and we are
adding directly our domain models who
see the database models here
there's no database models we map at the
runtime the database models to our
domain we operate solely with the domain
models we are adding to the database our
model calculation we get
using model calculation filter by ID get
by uid git by action and get all it
returns a list of model calculation s is
just SQL Alchemist sync so it's kind of
Orem Orem style to getting
uh to executing SQL queries we have
abstracted all of those things away from
our domain model schema validation
services and other stuff and now we have
that layer of the repositories
that means that we can obviously test it
without no database
how to test it we can fake our
repository add fake repository under
tests
what is a fake repository we can go to
the test because amazing fake repository
the fake calculation reports today still
implements the calculation repository
interface that means it does not violate
any kind of interface it's still
conforms the contract and for the sake
of Simplicity or testing we are faking
the database with a dictionary
then while adding the database it is the
actual insert we just stores this random
ID in a dictionary when getting back
from the ID we just use this ID as a
dictionary key get by uid which Traverse
from the dictionary if the the uid is
equal the uid that we are searching for
we return this model calculation and for
the get all we just return back the self
database itself
uh obviously uh so I expect to type this
calculation but got dick
is a fake repository so no need to Bossa
to correct everything just uh just use
it and then that means that we can test
repository we can add a test calculation
so test calculation test add calculation
we can we can get get fake repository
returning back a fake repository
instance you can check it from the from
the conf test and where it falls yeah
and get calculation model object which
is another fixture in the confidence we
just create a dummy
model and return it as a fixture to the
test calculation and then we somehow add
it
but obviously it's an addition to the
dictionary but imagine that it's a true
database connection and it's adding
there's nothing different with that and
you can get the dictionary values you
can test get calculation by uid you can
test get calculation by action test get
all calculations
and of course sake of the bravity let's
just install it
and test it
our repository test also passed that
means we have abstracted a way of our
database actions with a repository
pattern and even we write a unit test
without a database
because a database is
here is outside
it's a detail we don't need right now we
will need it in the future
uh the next
okay obviously with the databases we
need some kind of database migrations
and also this Orem now we are ready to
work with a real database
this is a ad alignment things the
alembic config Olympic has its own
configs and we store I store actually in
an adapters
in a DB this kind of the already
like configuration config change for
come from Olympics it's not nothing
fancy here
the rest Implement alembic database
migrations
I'm going to implement this
and now we have this origin pi and this
is a question answer to the question of
how you decouple the database layer from
the domain model
just install it
in order to not to see the threads
great so with SQL Alchemy Orem there are
two type of the mapping one is a
declarative mapping the declarative
mapping is you what you save is a Django
model you create a Django model for
example mode class user it in hers from
the Django model and this is the thick
layer decorative way of the actions but
there's a other kind of mapper with the
Orient is called classical mapper or
imperative mapper and we are using the
imperative mapper here we are creating a
metadata we register we are creating a
mapper registry and we declare the table
uh imperatively like manually what kind
of steps it should have it should have
ID uid Left Right action result created
add updated add any unique constraint
as you see this sync is a new
uh because it's from the database but
the rest of
the rest of the column is a copy like
the mapped copy of the our calculation
domain model
and SQL argument understands it when you
map it so we Define a start mappers
you have a bunch of 10 tables right you
stack the mappers inside the start
mappers function and you register the
you use map register with a map
impressively we implicitly
imperatively declare that of a model
calculation
mapped to the OEM calculation
and that way we keep clean
our domain models we do not import any
kind of odium like sync inside the
domain models domain model still stays
clean
but we have decoupled the Orient to the
outside and now if you see the arrow
origin itself depends on the model model
not depends so did you see that I wrote
the dependencies only on a slide and
this is a true way of treating the orium
as well Orem depends on the domain model
but not domain model depends on
on Orem
and two more short things the domain
model data data class used for SQL
Alchemy as a data sorry one more time
the domain model data class is used for
SQL Alchemy as a database table
representation what if the model needed
a relation to another database table
uh that's a good question this is a
actually the most naive way of
implementation of domain modeling
obviously you need to have Aggregates
accurate route and other stuff that acts
on top of the tables but I usually would
do if
uh you won't
to if you want to create a relation
without domain models you can create
here with the orium and Define the
relations in the map imperatively so
here you can Define the relations I
believe it's kind of uh
I need to find how it's doing
but this is the kind of thing that
properties yes properties you can Define
that okay model calculation and the
calculation then imagine that
so you have this cork
mapper than a different mapper stack of
the mappers and then you define the
relation between the mappers
this is a way of how you can do it the
relation with imperatively
thank you can one think of the domain
model as the interface for the database
or would this be a reversing of the
direction of dependency
okay
can one think of the domain model as the
interface for the database or would this
be a reversing of the direction of
dependency so
[Music]
I guess the question is about if we can
create a database models first
and then
create the domain models on top of that
or revert no it's not the way that we
should do because a domain model our
domain models is a simple they has no
business Logics it has no aggregate
aggregate through some kind of other
stuff in it it's just a value object but
imagine that you have this big domain
model which has a heart like business
logic solving some kind of problem it's
nothing related to the database itself
uh it should domain model should solve
the problem of the domain and that's why
you should first tackle with with the
domain model no databases sorry thanks
yes
but now we have two places where the
fields of the calculation model are
defined if we change the model we will
also need to change the table
yes this is a the idea behind this if
your domain model changed then sub the
rest of the things should be changed
because this is a core of your
application and now as you see it now
Orem depends on the domain models but
imagine the vice versa you are going to
change the database tables fields and
everything is breaking down but at least
with this strategy your test will pass
accept some kind of database this so I
think if you use alembic here the there
will also be some sort of a migration
process helping you sure and then you
come back to the like SQL alchem Orem to
change the fields then run the Creator
migrations and the run the migrate right
one last thing maybe why do you inherit
the repository in fake repository
instead of using the real one and mock
the methods
uh this is a like battle between
um
testing strategies that mock stops I
don't know if the apocal
uh what I see uh the my idea related to
the MOX if it's getting more
I lose attraction with the mocks where
to I did a MOG when I did a mug why I
did more and this over complicates the
testing strategy and I am using the
fakes this is a getting the same result
more clean way and even your fake
repository like fake classes should
conform with your with your interfaces
or in that way you ensure that you do
not violate the interface there as well
so using real we are going to use the
real actually database connection but
with fake dependency injector container
it's nothing related to the actual
database we just
um we just make a connection to the
sqlite if it's test and then the
production database but inside the
dependent injection container we will
see it
oh yeah
oh man 12 okay let's just uh let's just
go through quickly uh and the at the end
we have a questions uh so we have
implemented repository but we are
missing the repository pattern the
atomic actions with the database so we
have not if you say that we have no
commit unroll back things
for creating this kind of stuff we are
going to use a pattern called unit of
work and let's just implement it quickly
uh
[Music]
yeah we haven't so again the port size
is an interface let's just go with
adapters because it's real
implementation so calculation SQL
Alchemy unit of work the name indicates
that this is the using the SQL Alchemist
this is a unit of work pattern and for
the domain model of the calculation it
implements calculation unit of work
interface and we have defined this as a
complex manager with a class what it has
it has a session Factory session Factory
came from the SQL
this actual connection when we use whiz
unit of work we enter to this portion as
a context manager and we open a
connection
we open a connection to the database
when we need it with
with unit of work we have a connection
then we have a calculation which is
calculation SQL outcome repository so we
operate on top of the reports to the
pattern we're using this unit of work
and obviously when we the context
manager exits it's we are going to close
the database connection we have Commit
which is calling this SQL alchem commit
we have this rollback which is using
this session rollback just as SQL all
kind of things
and obviously we need we can test it
right let's just first restructure our
test folders
now we have this domain reports to the
services
the test forgers and the next is ADD
fake
unit offer we have fake Repository
we can use it inside the fake unit of
work as pretended let's go back to the
test unit of flux and before that fake
UAV the fake UAV we're faking the
calculation unit of work just we say
that okay self-committed false and the
self calculation we do not need a
session inside the enter because we have
no actual database connections that's
why we have omitted it but we inject a
fake calculation repository inside
inside the the context manager
and when we the self-commit is committed
to roll back
just passed because we don't care about
the rollback nothing to roll back with a
fake and if you go to the test
calculation UAV now the magic happens
here with gate fake UAV we have a great
connection to the database and then we
use gate fake UAV calculation at this
calculation is a repository
this is an exact copy of the test what
we did in the report study
as you see but the thing is that now we
operate with the repository pattern
um repository pattern using unit of work
we have added extra abstraction over the
repository and I believe that we can
install it
and then even
hopefully test it
yes all tests are passed so without any
kind of database we have operated to
create an abstraction using grip poster
and unit of work we have fully tested it
uh yeah Magic
good so next
just quickly uh so we don't need it and
now with the most interesting part that
we have units of work repository domain
model and all the stuff even orium but
how the things wired up together now the
dependency injection container comes to
the land of the uh workshop and feature
add production di container let's just
cherry pick it
the eye container is the con it's a
thing that came from the dependence
injector Library it's quite really neat
and a powerful Library you can use it
and if we go to the layers
we have added this configurator which
has settings
the settings is just the DB URI like
database connection string and I use uh
the like extracting a message for each
settings as well this is pretty neat and
clean way if you want the settings URL
just call this gate database URI and it
will extract the proper settings for you
and inside the containers
the inside the container we have this
containers declarative container and we
get the database urli we create an
engine this is an SQL Alchemist thing as
you see we open we create an engine
and we Define default session Factory
which is a laptop function with a
session maker this is an actual database
connection so it's going to open the
connection what we Define as a Lambda it
will be used later in a unit of work we
don't need to open a connection directly
inside the dependence injection
container we delegate it
and the calculation UAV will provide a
factory is the providers that means a
dependency provider with actual
calculation SQL community of work and we
inject the session Factory as a default
session Factory
obviously
the thing is that
yeah if you go to the SQL community of
work it expects a session Factory and
it's a callable and indeed we just and
indeed we
we just injected the callable with a
Lambda so it gets what it expects
and let's just install I see some kind
of weird radish thing
quickly quickly quickly Fair container
amazing we need the fake container for
faking our dependencies
and a fake container is an is a copy of
so hardcore the DB connection if you
want here
like a fake container should open a
connection to the fake database or SQL
Lite at least or your development and
you can create like the dev container
staging container to manage your
dependencies properly
and from the settings I believe we have
changed the settings now if the test
runs there we are going to return sqlite
if there is no test run that means we
are going to use a production connection
um that's pretty good
okay
we are going to implement the
integration test
uh integration test I'm going to show
show immediately
um
yeah if we mark it as an integration we
get we get the calculation unit of work
from the fake container we actually add
the calculation model then this is a
true commit
this is aware that actual database use
and then we check that if the database
has these values added so this is a
um actually the
black test integration test for our
working we have fake tests with the
calculation unit of work now we have
integration test with the calculation
units
uh
uh no no no
oh yeah
so then the next layer
but uh
I feel that we are running out of time
but just this quickly if we add the next
layer with a use case
let's just go through the use case and
I'm going to try to pick all of them
just not to
if you're not to watch the time
I think all your ideas and getting all
and then immediately go to the adapters
and adapters we have these use cases
which is actual things that we are
everything wired up together they
calculate use case in implements a
calculate use case interface it has unit
of work dependency and it has a service
dependency the calculation unit of work
interface and operands service interface
the question can arise okay this is it
dependence is an interface where is the
actual
instances of this class and this is the
magic of the dependence injection
container it's injected dynamically by
provider dependency injection provider
and if you go to The Container we have
the operand service we have a calculate
use case and it injected to the use case
and the runtime as you see we have this
we are checking from we are getting the
actual object from the dependence
instruction container using this
key key detect key notation
and then inside the ad we calculate the
result we save the information
with the result then we subtract we
multiply and other stuff we have this
get all get by uid which is pretty the
similar things that we open a database
connection we get by uid and if we have
the result we return back as a
dictionary this is a use case do we have
time in a minute oh
actually have a few more minutes like
two or three or so we have a number of
questions I'm I bet there is more
content on your slides but I don't think
we will have the time for all of us it's
just the last part that the first API
then rush through it maybe if you can
yeah yeah just uh we have this that
everything is placed and then we have
this adding first API calculation and
let's just quickly go through the entry
points entry point is a is a layer that
we hit enter to our application we have
API we we have V1 and root calculator
let's just try to pick everything and
here you just address
okay sure sure thank you
so obviously people are asking for the
questions okay then we switch over to
the remaining questions
um finally the one waiting here for the
longest time what are ports and adapters
by the way
it's another name of the hexagonal
architecture with the
from the original author and the name is
ports and adapters architecture but the
people name attack hexagonal as well so
as you see the port is a contract that's
putting it simple the adapter these are
actual implementations so ports and
abstraction an interface and adapters is
actual implementation of these
interfaces putting it simple
how easy thanks how easy is it to change
the database adapter and use a
non-database storage for example Json or
some text file
as we have decoupled our domain model
from the Orem side you can shift with
oriums anytime
at which point should I use a more
Enterprise suitable programming language
AKA should a service like this even be
implemented in Python
this is a question that what we
struggle with so python is considered
for a long period of the years as a
scripting language but we love it and
know that it can be applied to the
Enterprise level as well but the thing
is that we were missing a teaching
materials on Enterprise architectures
specifically implementation is a python
versus Java or c-sharp because they have
been using this like 15 years or 20
years and this is a relatively new thing
for the python ecosystem I bet that the
python can be used in any kind of
application complexity
and there's one last one here on the
list which makes a last overall question
what advice would you give a developer
to not overthink the solution think
technical implementation and focus on
the domain and not mix the different
layers
wow
that's a hard question but the thing is
that we should change our the mindset on
how we are going to develop the
application the first thing that we
should adopt in ourselves asking a lot
of questions understanding the domain
and what kind of problem we are going to
fix to asking a lot of questions to the
stakeholders or your manager I don't
know Tim lead try to understand the
domain and then fix this with fake
repository with I don't know you you
don't need the database you can store it
in a txt file as well right but you can
show demo something and the thing is
that if your application your what your
code just fix the core domain problem
the rest of it of the things are details
so just focus on the domain what kind of
problem you are working with and fix it
first then think about oh we need to
choose a framework and we need to choose
a type of a database we need to choose I
don't know we have to store the logs we
have to store the monitoring metrics and
other stuff this is all the details
thank you very much I think that was a
very nice I think that was a very nice
exercise in adding a lot of overhead to
a simple calculation as we have seen
nevertheless I think you will also agree
that on larger systems this will pay off
yes definitely this is the idea thank
you thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]